in your opinion who's the top five you
know goats of all time like you know
forget to wait forget if they're retired
forget anything who's top five for you
this one's hard because I I am very
conflicted on Jon Jones because of the
the failed drug tests I feel like once
you've once you've failed a drug test
you somewhat pull yourself out of the
goat talk
um but I feel like Jon Jones is the most
dominant fighter of all time with the
asterisk of he has failed some drug
tests by the way what drugs did he was
he I don't know it was some kind of
performance enhancement and I mean I
think that and I mean he was he's openly
parties he's yeah well and I'm I'm not
okay with that I don't condone that but
that's but I also look at that
separately
enhancers yeah
um I think the I think the best
but
I would put over top over him would be
George Saint Pierre because of the way
he carried himself he did have some
losses like Jon Jones is essentially
undefeated he's never lost he lost one
fight by DQ
um the elbow in the face yeah
yeah so painful so he technically he
lost but he definitely really we had a
GSB here what six months yeah
gsp's to me the goat um I think
um
I do
wow I didn't like that though I like
that well I think just because I think
GSP I mean maybe maybe it was because I
shared the same weight class and at the
same time as Habib so I didn't look at
him as much of a legend like I do like
when I was coming up and I was in in
college I was watching George St-Pierre
versus Matt Hughes and all of these
other guys and the sport has evolved
obviously over the years
um
habib's strength of schedule compared to
George St Pierre's I think they're
pretty pretty similar but I would put
George as number one I would put Habib
as probably
number two Anderson Silva
number three
and then
um
I'm a DC guy I love DC you know DC
essentially only really lost to Jon
Jones and I think he lost to
who else maybe one other fight Cormier
yeah he just got into the Hall of Fame
too right yeah DC DC will be in my top
five
um you got one more got one more dang
I'm really I'm really not good he took
John out yeah I mean I I gotta take John
out John Jones
Cormier and you said Anderson Silva
Anderson Silva yeah but John's on in
there John's not I'm building up what
he's saying I can't I can't play John
you got one more in mine oh doggone I
don't know uh honestly
jail piece on it I loved it now I mean
he's
from like greatest fighters of all time
from record and winning world titles and
all that kind of stuff but when it comes
to the full package of hey yeah I mean
you could put like a Nate Diaz type of
guy in there where it's like hey Diaz
fights we're watching who do you put as
a showman showman outside Connor's at
the top but who do you put on uh showman
showman would be chair will be number
two Diaz is number three
Diaz is not a showman Diaz isn't even
trying to be a showman he just looks
like a showman to so many people because
he that's is who he is I mean which is
so great good good for him he can just
be authentically whoever he is the young
man yeah and like smacking people and
you know smoking throwing water bottles
yeah you know you know Connor's doing
what he's doing it's
yeah you got to love those guys though
the Diaz brothers yeah so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]